[Musik]
für die EU-Politiker Wolfgang Schäuble
sagt Deutschlands ansehen ist schwer
beschädigt und erklärt dem Handelsblatt
dass die Weltlage nie so bedrohlich war
wie heute die Bundesbank hat für den
Fall von Stromausfällen die
Bargeldbestände aufgestockt droht uns
ein Betrag Winter meine wunderbare Gäste
heute Abend sind die Ex-Grüne Anti haben
genau sie befürchtet der schlimmste für
die deutsche Wirtschaft und voll einen
radikalen regierungsumbau 8:15 Uhr
Schäfer wird da vermutlich nicht
widersprechen ich bin gespannt er sagt
auf jeden Fall heute abend uns geht es
nicht so gut wie die Regierung behauptet
Bestsellerautor Michael Nast er hat ein
ganz besonderes Thema mitgebracht und
zwar das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen
er sieht diese staatliche Instrument als
Lösung gegen flüchtlingskrise
coronakrise und vielleicht auch für die
Energiekrise auch mit von der Partie
Christoph Meyer der stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende FDP fordert einen
Neustart für Deutschland nicht
beschäftigen in diesen Tagen die Stars
der Grünen Außenminister
Blog und Wirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck wie der SPIEGEL berichtete soll
zwischen den beiden nämlich eine grüne
Eiszeit herrschen wir erinnern uns
Anfang 2008 als die beiden die Führung
der Grünen übernahmen legten sie ihre
Büros zusammen und lieferten der Presse
am Laufband gemeinsame Fotos die
Harmonie der beiden ja das wollförmlich
überaus den Fotos wie Kitsch doch damit
soll er jetzt Schluss sein bei der
gasumlage sprang einer Lena baerbock
Habeck nicht zur Seite und aus der
latenten Konkurrenz der beiden die durch
die Kanzlerfrage eingeläutet wurde soll
eisige Rivalität entstanden sein wie es
Leute im Bundestag schildern wenn man
auf den Unmut vieler Bürger mit der
grünen Politik blickt kommt natürlich
die Frage auf können sich die Grünen
nicht mal mehr selbst leisten das war
jetzt etwas überspitzt aber ich frage
mal Jan Schäfer als Leiter des Politik
und Wirtschaft Resorts bei Bild wie
steht es denn zwischen einer Lena
Werbung und Robert haben Weg ja du hast
das eigentlich ganz gut beschrieben die
haben das in den letzten Wochen ja auch
immer wieder
bei uns online in der Zeitung oder auch
bei BTV dokumentiert das aus den
ziemlich besten Freunden eigentlich
mittlerweile ziemlich beste Feinde
geworden sind haben auch mal die Frage
gestellt wie sehr sich Annalena baerbock
eigentlich über den Absturz von Robert
Habeck freut denn wir wissen ja auch das
ging ja auch mal andersrum wenn wir an
den Sommer 2021 denken kurz vor der
Bundestagswahl dann war es Anna Lena
bärburg die in sehr sehr schwerer See
war als grüne Kanzlerkandidatin und
keinen richtigen Beistand eigentlich von
ihrem ko-partei Chef Robert habe
erfahren hat und das geht jetzt in
umgekehrter Weise so das ist brutal Frau
Hermann noch weiß ja auch ein bisschen
wie die Grüne Partei funktioniert ähm
das ist brutal so ist Politik und Anna
Borg hatte auch ein langes Gedächtnis
und weiß noch ganz genau was Robert
Habeck nicht gesagt hat im letzten
Sommer vor der letzten Sommer und Wasser
gesagt hat und das war nicht besonders
hilfreich für Sie und so ist das Spiel
der Politik jetzt ist sie oben auf und
er unten und am Ende ist ganz klar steht
eine Bundestagswahl 25 und auf die
schielen beide das heißt Annalena
baerbock kann es nur recht sein dass
Robert Habeck aktuell wahrscheinlich
anders machen ja die Grünen wollen sie
jetzt wahrscheinlich anders machen die
hatten ja damals den beiden die
Entscheidung überlassen und jetzt soll
es aber ja vielleicht auch eine Urwahl
geben wer dann als Kanzlerkandidat
antreten wird war denn dann die Harmonie
und alles nur gespielt oder hat sich das
einfach so entwickelt weil man hat ja
schon wirklich gedacht die haben bald
ein paar Namen so wie Jennifer Lopez und
Ben Affleck hätte man sich fast auch
noch von den beiden eine aufbekommen
218219 in dieser Phase waren die Grünen
Oppositionspartei und wollten unbedingt
in die Bundesregierung und hatten immer
wieder ein Höhenflug und dann hätte der
ab und das gemeinsame Ziel war schon die
Grünen nach einer langen Periode in
Opposition wieder in die Regierung zu
führen und das schmeißt natürlich auch
zusammen eine Partei die ja von Flügel
kämpfen lebte beziehungsweise daran auch
immer wieder halb zugrunde ging die
brauchte Kommentar an der Spitze was
diese Partei zusammenführt stark macht
auch so etwas wie ein chorgeist
entwickelt einen neuen kurgeist und das
muss man sagen haben die beiden
hinbekommen aber am Ende ist immer die
Frage jeder Politiker Christoph Meier
weiß das auch wenn am Ende irgendwie
auch Macht haben und es ist dann schwer
zu entscheiden ja er oder ich ähm und
genau das ist bei den Grünen passiert
das hat Robert habe ich sehr stark
getroffen dass er Annalena bärbock den
Vortritt leisten musste hat ihr das so
gut es ging aus seiner sich dann auch
Heim gezahlt in schwierigen Situation na
gut aber es ist auch payback time jetzt
für Anna Lena Werbung und das sehen wir
jetzt also es geht um das Ziel wer wird
Kanzlerkandidat 2025 und da ist jeder
Meter den Annalena bärburg vor Robert
habe liegt aus ihrer sich gut und
umgekehrt ärgert sich natürlich Robert
Habeck über jeden Meter den er hinter
sich zurückfällt aber ehrlich mal muss
uns das denn interessieren was in den
beiden vorgeht die Lage ist doch viel zu
ernst dafür dass wir uns damit
beschäftigen ob das ein oder andere
selfie mit den beiden geklappt hat oder
nicht wir haben keine
fortschrittskoalition mehr weil die Lage
sich total verändert hat wir haben
einfach einen völlig anderes Jahr 2022
als das Jahr 2021 war dafür können die
Parteien nichts aber die Pläne können
jetzt eigentlich auf den Müllhaufen der
Geschichte die müssen sich alles neu
ausdenken finde ich also ich würde gerne
ein betonier halten für diesen
Industriestandort Deutschland der kommt
mir zu kurz bei dem was die
Bundesregierung macht das sage ich ganz
deutlich ich vertrete auch viele
Mittelständler ich arbeite wie
Mittelständler
bleiben wir noch einmal bei den Grünen
weil warum warum
ich das nicht so spannend finde und
warum ich das heute mitgebracht habe mit
einer in der Werbung und Robert habe ist
ja die wurden ja schon auch gewählt weil
sie immer diese Harmonie zu Schau
gestellt haben wir sind anders wir
machen die Frauenquote bei uns hat die
Frau den Vortritt wir sind die
moralischen wir reden das alles jetzt
zeigt sich ja anscheinend das ist ja ja
gar nicht so das ist ja fast wie schon
wieder eine grüne Lüge so wirkt es auf
mich na ja das ist die Inszenierung das
ist einfach nur die Inszenierung
Parteien inszenieren sich das ist völlig
normal und die Grünen haben immer schon
gerne Ping Pong gespielt dann hat man
immer einen oder Aufmerksamkeit steht
wenn der andere nicht in der
Aufmerksamkeit steht das ist eine
Inszenierung da würde ich mich jetzt
nicht weiter echauffieren das ist eben
der gewählte Weg der Grünen sage ich
jetzt mal der Punkt ist war schon immer
so das war schon immer so und ähm ja die
haben meistens aber keine Doppelspitzen
das ist immer schon Kniff in der
Inszenierung aber ich würde das nicht
überbewerten die Frage ist viel mehr was
denn eigentlich jetzt das Rendezvous der
Grünen insgesamt mit der Wirklichkeit
bedeutet auch für uns alle
ich glaube wir müssen natürlich
beachten das natürlich beide in der
Öffentlichkeit sehr gehypt waren vor der
Bundestagswahl und am Ende müssen wir
sehen dass beide quasi kein Übermenschen
sind was normales was normal ist ich
habe den Eindruck dass Robert habe
gerade lernt dass nur den Erklärbär
geben nicht ausreicht er hat mit dem
Wirtschaftsministerium Wirtschaft und
Energieministerium die zentrale Position
in dieser Bundesregierung und ähm wir
hoffen alle wir erwarten dass er da
jetzt guten Vorschläge mit dem
Finanzminister zentrale Position aber
für genau die Themen die jetzt relevant
sind gerade für die Industrie gerade für
die Wirtschaft aber auch für die
Menschen draußen über
gaspreisbremsen über Strompreis Bremsen
reden dann ist das das Thema wo dran
Herr Habeck wachsen oder scheitern kann
mehr von beiden habe ich glaube momentan
keiner von beiden nervten nervt mich
aber ich glaube schon dass er habe
momentan in der zentrale Rolle ist und
zeigen muss dass er den Job gewachsen
ist
wie ist es denn bei ihnen Herr Nast ja
ich habe ja in dieser Sendung
damals für atemloses Schweigen gesorgt
als ich gesagt habe was ich die Grünen
wählen werde aber Monster zu sagen dass
durch diese kumpelhaftigkeit oder dieses
eigentlich dieses duzen in diesem dieses
Image scheiße ich kann diese Leute also
ich habe echt gerade generellen Problem
mit der der oberen sei mal politischen
Kaste die irgendwie ernst zu nehmen also
bei uns im Bekanntenkreis wir nennen die
alle mit Vorhaben weil da ist überhaupt
kein
respektiert wird also das sind irgendwie
was ist ganz ganz seltsam dass ich das
also es ist fehlt wirklich die Frage
heute noch wählen
ja
trotz der Unzufriedenheit ja die
Unzufriedenheit das sind doch alles
imagegeschichten ich meine interessant
ist ja was ich bei Robert Habeck oder
Robert wie ich ja sage in gut finde ist
ja interessant finde ist dass er ein
ganz anderen rhetorischen Stil hat
wieder mit den Leuten redet er sagt
letztendlich wir haben so Pläne wir
wollen das Umsetzen geht aber nicht
kriegen wir nicht hin Realpolitik aber
so ist das halt ja aber ich glaube die
Frage die letztendlich war wirklich mal
stellt werden sollte unabhängig von
diesem das ist ja alles das ist das
Boulevard diese diese das ist doch hier
nein diese diese dieses Thema
letztendlich was du ja auch gesagt was
sie hier aufgebaut haben warum ist ein
massives Vertrauen in die Politiker
eigentlich
warum fehlt dann Vertrauen und das ist
manchmal diskutieren was ist das Problem
und aktuell in Deutschland genau
die richtig gebracht
das finde ich gut weil es nämlich
außerordentlich viele Menschen gibt
mehrere Millionen viele Millionen
vielleicht sogar in Deutschland die
haben jetzt echter Existenzsorgen und
das betrifft jetzt nicht nur Leute
vielleicht im Hartz iv-bezug sondern das
betrifft auch sehr viel in der
Mittelschicht Deutschland hat sich immer
dadurch ausgezeichnet durch den
Mittelstand eine Wirtschaftsform zu
pflegen die eine breite Mittelschicht
ermöglicht hat anders als in anderen
europäischen Ländern dadurch war ja auch
immer sehr viele Frieden die Franzosen
sind viel schneller auf der Straße als
die Deutschen dafür gibt's Gründe auch
in dem sozialen Bereich da gibt's
interessante Bücher wie äh France
Peripherie oder so da kann man das Lesen
aber der entscheidende Punkt ist dass
diese Regierung und da kann ich auch die
FDP nicht ausnehmen
dass diese Regierung sich nicht
öffentlich sich nicht öffentlich zum
Industriestandort Deutschland bekennt
dass viele die in der Regierung agieren
bis hin ins Wirtschaftsministerium nach
meinem Dafürhalten zu wenig
wirtschaftlichen und finanzielle
Sachverstand erkennen lassen dass die
immer maximal verunsichert sind das ist
aber schlimm weil diese agilen zwei bis
drei Millionen sozusagen die Leute
beschäftigen und Lohn und Brot bringen
sind eigentlich das Schwungrad unserer
Gesellschaft und wenn die überlegen ob
sie noch Investitionen machen wenn wir
überlegen ob sie ihre Bude zum ersten
ersten zumachen müssen wegen der
Energiepreise wenn sie überlegen dass
große Investitionen von ausländischen
Investoren nicht mehr stattfinden weil
man Deutschland und Europa nicht mehr
anpeilt sondern lieber nach China geht
nach Abu Dhabi oder in die USA dann
haben wir einen veritables Problem denn
die Deutschen sind nicht per se Reich
wir haben auch nicht genug Rohstoffe die
hier wie die Russen dann weltweit
verkaufen können zu guten Geld sondern
wir müssen Produkte veredeln das setzt
eine unglaubliche Tiefe in der
Technologie und in der Fertigung voraus
und wenn wir diese Prozesse stören auch
durch fehlende Politik die gravieren
sind ein halbes Jahr lang nicht zu
reagieren nach dem Ausbruch des Krieges
in der Energiefrage ist ein verdammtes
Versäumnis und hat jetzt zu den
Problemen geführt die man haben wir
haben zu Höchstpreisen jetzt die
gasspeich eingefüllt um wenigstens diese
Sicherheit herzustellen aber das sind
25% unseres jahresbedarfes und hatten
man leichten Oktober und leicht November
aber das wird sich alles ändern und wir
haben einen veritables Problem mit der
Wirtschaft die ist jetzt unter voraus
vor Herausforderungen gesetzt die wir
vorher nicht hatten Corona war ein
Testfall da ist aber um die
Dienstleister gegangen wir reden jetzt
vom industriellen Herzen dieses Landes
und ich erwarte einfach dass alle Kräfte
konzentriert werden darauf die
industrielle Substanz dieses Landes zu
halten und damit im Prinzip unseren
Kapitalstock als Bundesrepublik
Deutschland stabil zu halten das auch
für die Europäer wichtig wenn wir
versagen ist ganz Europa betroffen aber
wenn ich das einmal zusammenfassen waren
also vor der die Industrialisierung
dieses Landes ja ob sie nun Absicherung
passiert aber was wäre dann die Lösung
der Regierungswechsel naja also meine
Vorschlag ist wir brauchen eine
Regierung der nationalen Verantwortung
und der Vernunft das können auch die
jetzt agierenden Parteien sein wenn sie
Vernunft annehmen und ich kann nicht
nachvollziehen dass wir uns riesigen
unter Strom Versorgung ans Bein binden
wenn wir die AGRAVIS weiterlaufen lassen
könnten die sechs AKWs oder wenn wir in
der Kohle vielleicht noch mal überlegen
mit CCS zu arbeiten wenn es da also das
Karten capture wenn es darum geht dass
man Kohlendioxid aus der Atmosphäre
raushält gibt es Techniken auch die
Kohle anders zu gestalten und das zu
machen und Atomkraft ist sowieso bei den
ganzen Umweltschützern außerhalb
Deutschlands anerkannte ökotechnik also
was soll der Quark wir riskieren ja auch
die Wirtschaft der anderen Nachbarländer
da rennen sie bei der FDP sicherlich
offene Türen ein wir müssen allerdings
feststellen dass nachdem die Ampel die
Regierung übernommen hat wir unabhängig
von dem Krieg Russland gegen die Ukraine
einfach eine ganze Menge Defizite geerbt
haben also das Thema verkaufte
Energiewende ist ein originäres Thema
von der großen Koalition von der CDU das
Thema das nicht in Zukunft Technologien
in der im Land investiert wurde ist ein
originäres Thema was die CDU mit Frau
Merkel vorneweg zu beantworten hat dass
wir in der Sicherheitspolitik nicht
vorangekommen sind dass die Bundeswehr
kaputt zu stark sind sind alles Themen
die am Ende des Tages mit der CDU nach
Hause gehen und jetzt haben wir in der
Tat die Situation dass wir da haben bin
ich vollkommen bei Ihnen die
industriellen Kerne unseres Landes
sichern müssen deswegen müssen wir über
die gasbremse reden wir müssen über die
strompreisbremse reden das hätte
schneller gehen können richtig wobei
auch das muss man der Fairness halber
sagen dass im Juni Juli die Situation
noch die war dass die Gaspreise nicht so
exorbitant hoch waren das soll jetzt
nicht verteidigen dass wir die
gaspreisbremse noch nicht auf dem Weg
gebracht haben das bmwk arbeitet noch
dran das Wirtschaftsministerium und wir
hoffen dass er weg jetzt bald eine
Vorlage ins Kabinett macht aber ich
glaube schon dass der Fokus auch dieser
Regierung darauf ist dass Arbeitsplätze
in diesem Land gesichert werden sonst
würden wir ja nicht mehrere 100
Milliarden Euro ausgeben um das
sicherzustellen aber wenn Energie aus
Russland nicht mehr zur Verfügung steht
dann kann man nicht von heute auf morgen
andere Energiequellen erschließen daran
arbeiten wir jetzt mit Hochdruck und die
Versäumnisse die die einheitig in der
einseitigen Abhängigkeit von russischen
pipeline-gas geschaffen wurden sind auch
ein Thema was die große Koalition in den
letzten Jahren zu fassen
wenn es so wäre dass man genug getan
hätte er nicht getan also nichts getan
hätte dann wären den Ländern ja jetzt
was weiter wir haben verschiedene
Regierungen in den Bundesländern es gibt
sogar eins von dem grünen
Ministerpräsidenten regiert wird dann
müssten die ja schon weiter sein man hat
sich immer auf Strom fokussiert man hat
fünf vier Fünftel das Energiemarktes
nicht betrachtet man hat sich nicht auf
Speichertechnologie konzentriert man
kann ja viel diskutieren aber es ist ja
auch in den Bundesländern nicht wirklich
wesentliches passiert zumindest in den
meisten nicht und die Frage die sich mir
stellt ist diese Energiewende wie sie
konzipiert wurde noch unter
Berücksichtigung auch von mir aus der
russischen Auslieferungen ist
ineffizient überteuert sie funktioniert
nicht wir schalten funktionierende
Stromversorgung ab für Stromversorgung
die nicht funktioniert das ist nicht
hinnehmbar das ist ein Industrieland
kein Agrarstaat also das ist doch alles
schadensbegrenzt das ist ja das krasse
und das ist ja das was ich an der
Politik stört ja also seit Jahren schon
ist alles nur schadensbegrenzungspolitik
es wir haben eine Krise was ist eine
Krise eine Krise ist ein Symptom eines
Zustands und die ganze Zeit beschäftigen
uns mit Krisen und es wird uns als
Erfolg verkauft dass man irgendwas dabei
improvisiert das irgendwie dann
irgendwie das ein bisschen rettet aber
eine Krise aus einer Krise muss man
lernen ja man muss die Krise lösen oder
und dann guckt man sich worauf es
entstehen eigentlich diese ganzen Krisen
und dann das passiert halt nicht weil
dann schon wieder die nächste Krise
kommt aber wobei man sagen muss das ist
unterschiedliche Art von Krisen gibt
also die wenn wenn ein Land wie Russland
einen Krieg anzettelt und dann freies
Land überfällt dann ist ist eine Krise
die war jetzt nicht unbedingt
voraussetzbar aber das was Frau Hermenau
ja beschreibt ist eine Krise die sich ja
schon seit Jahren abzeichnet wenn man
nach Baden-Württemberg schaut und Herr
Meier sie haben das schön versucht alles
der CDU zuzuschieben ich erinnere mich
dass der zweite Atomausstieg unter einer
schwarz-gelben Regierung passiert ist
dann ist mein Eindruck gewesen dass in
den letzten 16 Jahren Angela Merkel
immerhin in 12 Jahren die
spd-koalitionspartner Waren der letzte
Vizekanzler ist Olaf schaut es jetzt
Bundeskanzler der hat alles mitgetragen
und wenn ich das richtig sehe dann sind
auch die Grünen in ganz ganz vielen
Bundesländern mit einer Regierung bzw
Baden-Württemberg 10 Jahre und wenn man
sich
[Gelächter]
Baden-Württemberg aufgestellt werden
dann ist das Ganze Schreien der Grünen
ein Schrein wirklich in dem Fall gegen
den Wind es ist ein verlogenes schreien
weil die Grünen selbst nicht in der Lage
sind die Energiewende die sie wollen so
zu treiben wie es nötig wäre wenn man es
denn so wollte aber der Punkt den vorher
noch macht den Einsatz den sag ich noch
oder sind zwei ist ja dass wir hier äh
ein Wirtschaftsstandort quasi
sukzessive schreddern indem wir das
Kernkapital was wir haben nämlich
günstige und den großen Teil noch
unabhängige Energie dass wir uns dieses
Vorteiles berauben und wenn man in der
Koalition sich in Berlin umhört er auch
in ihrer Partei und mit Politikerinnen
und Politikern spricht über die Frage
was ist denn eigentlich wenn das
Ökostrom Ziel 80% im Jahr 20 30
Schrägstrich 32 nicht erreicht wird was
passiert
was die Antwort ist die Antwort ist es
muss er reinigt werden aber das ist
Antwort ja
kommen wir doch ein bisschen noch mal
also zum einen wir haben Krisen wir
haben letztlich zwei schwarze Schwäne
mit Corona und mit dem äh dem Krieg in
der Ukraine oder Pandemie selbst vorbei
richtig glücklicherweise aber wir hatten
jetzt drei Jahre im Ausnahmezustand so
und deswegen ist es richtig dass wir uns
in der Zeit angucken müssen was davor an
Vorbereitung falsch gelaufen ist wir
müssen in der konkreten Krise zunächst
erstmal löschen das tut diese
Bundesregierung mit viel Geld da kann
man darüber diskutieren ob das effizient
alles eingesetzt wird und dann muss man
anschließend die leeren rausziehen und
das kann keine Lehre sein zu sagen es
muss funktionieren sondern am Ende das
hat Christian Linda auch gesagt haben
wie gesagt wir müssen über Schiefer
Gasförderung sprechen wir müssen darüber
reden dass wir heimische fossile
Energieträger wieder fördern das kann
nicht sein dass die ganze Zeit aus
Amerika LG Gas einführen was über der
Fördermethoden gewonnen wird was wir in
Deutschland nicht haben wollen und wir
müssen uns ehrlich machen
es gab bisher kein gesellschaftlichen
Konsens die Atomkraftwerke länger laufen
zu lassen Herr Söder hat aber das hat
sich doch eine Bevölkerung geändert Herr
Söder hat noch gesagt wenn bis Ende 22
die Atomkraftwerke nicht abgeschaltet
werden den tritt er zurück so also
deswegen muss man ganz ehrlich sagen ich
haben sich viele Leute würden
wir darüber reden dass wir einmal eine
ganz schnell Zwischenfrage stellen mir
fällt das immer wieder auf bei
Politikern in dieser Runde da müssen wir
uns ehrlich machen das heißt wir haben
sonst meine unehrliche Politik gehabt am
Ende am Ende muss es darum dass
diejenigen die sich vielleicht geirrt
haben die vielleicht ein Stück weit auch
Lebenslügen hinterher gerannt sind
bereits sind zu akzeptieren dass sie
sich gehört haben und das ist ne das
Thema hatten wir eben in nach meiner
Einschätzung in weiten Teilen natürlich
auch die grüne Politik die uns in diesem
in diese Energiewende in den
Nullerjahren quasi so vorangebracht hat
dass der Bundesrechnungshof schon vor 45
Jahren gesagt hat nirgendwo wie in
Deutschland ist die Energiewende so
teuer und so effizient umgesetzt worden
genau diese Eingeständnisse sind ja sehr
nett aber Frau herbenau wenn ich Sie
richtig verstanden habe sie wollen ja
Taten sehen und nicht immer nur ehrlich
fragen wir brauchen Rache großen Piraten
mehr ich will auch nicht mehr täglich
den Lernfortschritt irgendwelcher
Minister nachverfolgen müssen das ist
mir eigentlich zu intellektuell zu wenig
ja ich möchte gerne dass wir ein klares
Bekenntnis zum Industriestandort haben
das bedeutet dass man nicht
Flickschusterei betreibt an Symptomen im
Moment sondern das bedeutet dass man
sagt wir setzen die Energiewende jetzt
einfach mal drei vier Jahre oder 5 Jahre
alt wollen Sie eine neue Regierung oder
nicht neu sein die muss neu Arbeiten
verstehen Sie also es kann auch gerne
sein dass der Olaf Scholz in den sauren
Apfel beißt und den Friedrich Schmerz
Vorschläge kommen wir machen eine große
Koalition der Vernunft und der Friedrich
Schmerz beißen dafür müsste es ja mal
sehen der Friedrich Schmerz beiß den
anderen sauren Apfel und sagt naja gut
dann werde ich halt nicht mehr Kanzler
wenn beide Männer das ertragen was für
eine Frage ist die manstellen darf
die Frage dass man dann einen größeren
Pool an Leuten hat wo man noch mal neu
denken
weil ich Strauß ihm zu weil wir sind in
einer so der Solaranlage dass die
ausländischen Investoren um Deutschland
inzwischen einen Bogen machen es geht
nicht mehr darum ob wir bis zum Ostern
keinen Blackout gehabt haben das ist
nicht mehr die Frage die Frage ist ob
Deutschland noch als Industriestandort
auch außerhalb Deutschlands wahrgenommen
wird und da hat die Bundesregierung eine
Pflicht zu tun ich fand interessant dass
Herr Scholz nach China geflogen ist für
zwei Stunden Audienz und mit über 16
Milliarden Euro Auftrag wieder kam für
Airbus und damit die Amerikanern das
fand ich schlaue Sache und so muss das
eigentlich laufen hat keiner drüber
gesprochen aber das ist wichtig so und
diese Sache müssen sich die Regierung
stellen und wenn sie die jetzige
Koalition nicht kann weil ein oder zwei
oder drei Leute einfach ein bisschen auf
ihre Programmierung Fixierung drauf sind
dann tut es mir leid dann müssen wir
eben eine andere Zusammensetzung der
Regierung nehmen hauptsache die Leute
machen das was nötig ist werden sie
nicht machen wenn die SPD sagt sie
möchte es nicht die CDU sagt sie möchte
sich dann ist das quasi genau derselbe
Vorhof den sie
80 Millionen Deutschen die sagen hier
muss man das vorangehen am Ende am Ende
haben wir Wahlen durchgeführt im letzten
Jahr und haben danach eine Koalition
gebildet es war so dass die CDU
nicht koalieren wollte oder konnte zu
damaligen Zeit ich hätte mir auch
gewünscht dass wir eher in Jamaika
Konstellation
nicht reden wollen würde das Problem war
ja das zum einen auch daher Söder gesagt
hat wir gehen in die Opposition zum
anderen war es so dass in den
Sondierungsgesprächen die wir hatten die
die Vertraulichkeit nicht hergestellt
war weil ständig gerade auch Richtung
Bild-Zeitung aus den Sitzungen eins zu
eins offensichtlich aus der
unionsperspektive raus
programmiert kann man da kann man sehen
aber man braucht ja eine Grundlage für
eine vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit und
die war einfach nicht da als das
Programm also ehrlich gesagt mich würde
jetzt weniger interessieren ob irgendwer
Nachrichten rausschickt als wir am Ende
das Programm im letzten Jahr war dass
wir eine jamaika-konstellation nicht
hinbekommen haben und zu Demokratie und
Wahlen gehört das anschließend Parteien
Kompromisse machen müssen in einem
Koalitionsvertrag und versuchen müssen
dann mit diesen Kompromissen aus ihrer
jeweiligen Programmatik das Beste für
das Land zu gestalten wir haben jetzt in
diesem Jahr besondere Herausforderung
wir haben alle nicht gesehen was ab
Februar hier an Belastung sowohl in der
Sicherheitspolitik als auch in den
Energiepolitik auf uns zukam und jetzt
sind wir im notbetrieben und jetzt geht
der größte Fehler in Robert habe bisher
gemacht ne ich glaube der
ich glaube dass
habe ich schneller in der Tat oder die
ganze Bundes Spannung schneller hätte
das Thema gaspreisbremse auf den Weg
bringen müssen natürlich bin ich der
Auffassung das haben wir gesagt dass wir
das Thema Kernenergie länger hätten
fahren
lassen
das wäre gut aber auf der anderen Seite
müssen wir auch da realistisch sein wir
reden ja also am Ende geht es ja nicht
nur darum theoretisch irgendwas zu
fordern es geht darum ob es eine
realistische
umsetzungswahrscheinlichkeit gibt und
nachdem der Bundeskanzler hier ein
Machtwort gesprochen hat nachdem wir die
einzige sind in dieser Konstellation
dieser Koalition die sagen wir wollen
die Atomkraftwerke länger laufen lassen
als bis April nächsten Jahres muss man
irgendwann akzeptieren dass der Drops
Beispiel
momentan keine politische Mehrheit da
und das muss man akzeptieren ich finde
es interessanter
dass wir jetzt zunächst erstmal darüber
reden ich sagtest dass wir über über
konventionelle Gasförderung in
Deutschland reden dass wir über
schiefergasförderung
plötzlich kommt alles aber die Frage ist
dafür 23 auf den Winter 23 4 schauen
sagt eine Wirtschaftspartei wie die FDP
ja ist jetzt mit grün und ich würde hier
gerne einmal müssen auch da ehrlich sein
nur weil wir drei Atomkraftwerke länger
laufen lassen werden wir nicht wir
werden eine Strompreis Entlastung haben
deswegen wollen wir es ja deswegen ist
es wichtig aber die Probleme die wir im
Winter 23 24 bekommen können wenn wir in
kalten Winter jetzt in diesem Jahr
bekommen werden wir nicht allein durch
das länger laufen lassen
20 Millionen haushalteversorgung mit
Strom
in Deutschland und das muss auch gemacht
werden ich würde jetzt gerne mal eine
Frage an Michael nass stellen hier in
der Runde
meine ganz große Frage ist jetzt hat es
Herr Meier denn geschafft sie können
jetzt eigentlich fdp-bilder werden oder
die Grünen sind jetzt nicht mehr ganz so
befreundet und jetzt nach diesem
Plädoyer für die Politik nein ich wie
gesagt ich verbunden
es geht nur noch irgendwie Reaktionen
und auch das hier auch es geht doch
nicht darum also was sie hier gerade
gesagt haben mit den Atomkraft werden 20
Millionen weiter wir müssen vielleicht
mal einen Schritt zurückgehen und ich
gucke mir vielleicht liegt daran dass
die Schriftsteller bin oder so ich gucke
mir eher den ich gucke ja in
Beschäftigung mit der mich mit der
Psyche oder mit dem Menschen ja und wir
beschäftigen uns hier eine Runde
eigentlich nur mit der Wirtschaft und
welches ist das das Problem auch also
ich habe auch den Eindruck dass
die Politiker in der heutigen Zeit
eher auf das reibungslose Funktionieren
der Wirtschaft Wert legen als auf den
Menschen zu gucken denn wir führen ja
ein Leben hauen sie den auch auf die
Menschen die die Gasrechnung nicht mehr
bezahlen können die Angst vor dem
glasrechnungen haben genau da werden wir
noch drauf kommen ich wollte nur sagen
wir kommen warum ja wirklich wichtig ist
dass wir jetzt die Kurve kriegen
es wird in geostrategischen
Veränderungen ist jetzt jeder muss
großartig überlegen in der
großwirtschaft wo er investiert ich habe
das vorhin bloß kurz angedeutet in
Europa und vor allen Dingen Deutschland
als ein potenzieller
Investitionsstandort von der Karte
genommen wird wenn die mehrere Optionen
haben haben wir mittelfristig ein
dramatisches Problem dass sofort soziale
Probleme hervorruft die Leute keine
hohen Gehälter mehr bekommen es gibt
Entlassungen wir können jetzt mal nur in
die Autobahn zu gucken auch andere da
war vorher schon der Wurm drin vor dem
Krieg mit den Russen und den Ukrainern
ich denke es ist entscheidend aus meiner
Sicht dass die Regierung jetzt sehr
schnell in wenigen Wochen noch vor
Jahresende dazu übergeht deutlich zu
machen dass die Absicht besteht dass
Deutschland ein industriestand dort
bleibt und das dafür weil die Realitäten
sich selbstständig
völlig geändert die Regierung erkennt
die Veränderung der Realitäten an und
passt ihre Programmatik an das ist
entscheidend in meinen Augen also vor
der neuen Koalitionsvertrag ja natürlich
wenn die Koalition das schafft kann sie
auch von mir aus weitere gehen sie muss
aber die Realitäten abbilden ja es gibt
ja nicht nur Probleme die die Wirtschaft
betreffen herr Meier sie haben uns ja
heute auch ein Thema mitgebracht
ja
hatte Überleitung ja noch nie hat
scheitern so viele Chancen eröffnet ich
beziehe mich natürlich auf die
landesfassungsgerichtssprechung gestern
war Wiederholung in Berlin Rot-Grün
linke sind in Berlin gescheitert wir
erleben jeden Tag aufs Neue dass ähm
linke Politik linke Ideologen diese
Stadt ins Chaos äh stürzen ob wir über
einen mietendeckel reden der von
Bundesverfassungsgericht gekippt werden
musste ob es über neubautätigkeiten geht
ob es darüber geht das Gerichte die
willkürliche ähm Sperrung von Straßen
für den Autoverkehr verhindern müssen ob
es das Bildungsdefizit in Berlin ist das
links grüne Märchen vom bullerbühnen
Berlin ist schon ziemlich abgebrannt und
Berlin ist mittlerweile ein Mahnmal wie
unkontrollierte linke Ideologen eine
Stadt ein Land kaputt machen können und
auf der anderen Seite sehen wir das
verwaltungschaos
das primär aufgrund der organisierten
Verantwortungslosigkeit zwischen Land
und Bezirken hier stattfindet keiner ist
für irgendetwas verantwortlich alle
wollen mitreden niemand übernimmt am
Ende die Entscheidungskompetenz und das
ist nicht in den letzten Tagen oder
Wochen passiert sondern am Ende des
Tages haben alle Parteien die in den
letzten 30 Jahren in Berlin
Regierungsverantwortung übernommen haben
das ist die SPD das ist die linke und
das sind die Grünen aber auch die CDU
sich hier darauf ein ähm oder sich
darauf ausgeruht dass diese
statistikfunktional ist und dass man
hier nicht allzu viel Politik für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger machen muss ich
als gebürtiger Berliner bin es leid mich
für die Berliner Stadtpolitik
entschuldigen zu müssen mich dafür
schämen zu müssen wie die
Landesregierung hier agiert und früher
war es so dass man Sport ertragen musste
wenn man sagte man ist in Berlin
politisch aktiv mittlerweile so dass man
bedauert oder dass man nur bedauern hört
das ist der Tiefpunkt den dieses
landesverfassungsgerichtsurteil
letztlich als Sinnbild jetzt auslöst und
deswegen ist der 12 Februar nächsten
Jahres eine Chance für ein wirklichen
Neustart in der Stadt und da müssen wir
glaube ich die die Stadt voranbringen
wollen alle daran arbeiten und glauben
dann geht es mit der Stadt auch wieder
voran dann haben wir auch wieder eine
Hauptstadt auf die man stolz sein kann
ich glaube Herr Meyer ganz viel Wahres
gesagt nicht wundern bloß drei von zwei
von den Parteien die hier regieren sind
Koalitionspartner ihre FDP im Bund und
so drastisch wie sie glaube ich dieses
Problem ja auch beschrieben haben und so
klar wie sie auch eine Aussage waren
muss man ehrlicherweise sagen
ist es sehr offen schwingt er glaube ich
sehr viel mit wie eigentlich es um die
Ampel im Bund bestellt ist weil sie
damit zwei Parteien koalieren mit denen
sie eigentlich über überhaupt nicht
zusammenpassen da ich sie haben das sehr
gut beschrieben die Linkspartei ist
sicherlich in Berlin mächtiger als sie
im dieses Gebietes ohne Frage aber
trotzdem haben sie es hier mit
SPD-Politikern und Grünen Politikern zu
tun unter anderem mit Frau Giffey die ja
sogar mal Bundesministerin gewesen ist
also sind genau die beiden Parteien die
sie hier attackieren mit der die FDP im
Bund regieren und mich wunderte wenn ich
das auch so höre ja
bis vor kurzem Bundesministerin gewesen
es ist ja richtig aber eine Auszeit
genommen hat auf Steuerzahler Kosten um
ihren Wahlkampf hier in Berlin
vorzubereiten das ist ja alles richtig
aber ich glaube die Berliner die
Berliner Grünen auch Sympathien
teilweise für Klima Kleber sind noch mal
ein bisschen anderer Schlag als
vielleicht die Grünen hier in
baden-weltministerin genauso gesehen hat
alles richtig sagen ja nicht am Anfang
also sagen nicht dass die Ampel ähm im
Bund meine politische
wunschkonstellation ist wir arbeiten den
Umständen entsprechend gut zusammen
aber wenn wir uns Berlin ansehen und wir
ansehen uns ansehen wie diese Stadt an
die Wand ge getan wurde dann muss man
feststellen dass die politische
Verantwortung dazu stehe ich unabhängig
davon was wir auf der Bundesebene an
Koalition haben dass die politische
Verantwortung dafür bei SPD grün aber
auch linken und CDU liegt und damit
haben wir mit dem 12 februar die
Möglichkeit eines und das muss man
nutzen das Problem liegt ja daran die
Umfragen zeigen ja schon es wird wenig
Veränderung geben lohnen sich diese neue
Wahlen jetzt überhaupt das werden wir
erstmal sehen ob ähm ob die also zum
einen Umfragen sind keine Wahlergebnisse
ist glaube ich starke FDP ich glaube
eine starke FDP ich glaube auch da daran
dass ich die Union auch in der
Opposition in Berlin Stück weit
regeneriert hat so dass wir die
Möglichkeit haben eine Alternative
darzustellen am Ende des Tages wenn wir
glauben
fast 90 Tage vor einer Wahl das Wahlen
nichts ändern denn ist das ein
fatalistischer Ansatz der glaube ich uns
allen nichts bringen
Menschen das Denken
habe dass wir hier in der Stadt gucken
was ist alles schief gegangen und was
kann man besser auf diesen Punkt von
Frau Hermenau ein der ist nämlich sehr
spannend den sie gerade gesagt haben
also die Wahlbeteiligungen sind ja
schlecht es war jetzt auch in
Niedersachsen so das ist in Osten schon
länger so das hat damit zu tun dass es
viele Menschen gibt die denken das
Wahlen nichts mehr ändern Wahlen sind
ein vorschussvertrauen an Politiker man
entscheidet sich und denkt die werden
das schon ordentlich machen so ungefähr
läuft das ja im Kopf ab und es gibt
immer mehr Menschen die wirklich eine
weinende Kabine stehen überlegen oh Gott
verdammt was streiche ich denn jetzt an
ne und das wird immer schwieriger und
das hat damit zu tun dass egal ob das
jetzt CDU SPD linke grüne oder FDP ist
sie kriegen immer dasselbe das ist
wurscht das ist glaube ich
wirklich nicht richtig na gut ähm denn
wir können uns ja auch zum Beispiel beim
Thema Schule mal Vergleiche anschauen im
traditionell rot regierten Bremen ist
der Schulsystem katastrophal das
traditionell schwarz regierte Bayern
kommt komischerweise auf exzellente
Werte wenn man das Thema Sachsen nimmt
beispielsweise erinner ich mich daran
dass eigentlich seitdem es gibt immer
ein ein CDU-Ministerpräsidenten das mag
durchaus etwas damit zu tun haben wie
Politik ist und wenn man sich in Berlin
anschaut dann macht er zumindest
Christoph mal den Eindruck als wenn er
etwas ändern wollte selbst wenn er mit
den roten und grünen aber ich glaube
dass das stimmt dann wäre es doch
eigentlich mal schlau dass wir uns
wieder mehr darauf konzentrieren dass
wir eine Föderation sind und dass wir
dann einfach den Bundesländern mehr
ihren eigenen Spielraum lassen und dann
bin ich aber auch dafür den
Länderfinanzausgleich runter zu fahren
und dann soll jedes Bundesland mal
zeigen was es drauf hat Berlin ist ein
interessanter Standort für Investoren
wenn es ordentlich gemanagt wird das ist
finde ich eine interessante
Herausforderung da könnte man viel
lernen berlin braucht möglicherweise
eine rot-grünes Modell das sage ich
jetzt ganz bewusst du ganz ganz
provokant weil Berlin diese knapp 9
Milliarden und 9 Milliarden aus dem
Länderfinanzausgleich auch sehr sehr gut
gebrauchen kann daneben viele Menschen
sehr sehr gut
mal sehen was Berlin für eine rollenden
Land hat ist ja eigentlich ihre
schaufensterfunktion also das Image der
Stadt ist der international es ist halt
die Stadt in Deutschland ja und es ist
halt auch kein Wirtschaftsstandort mehr
das heißt für Leute die schon seit
langer Zeit nicht mehr aber die Sache
ist mit welchen Geldern wurde Berlin zu
diesem schönen Schaufenster gemacht wo
wurde das Geld erwirtschaftet für das
schöne Schaufenster die Frage ob das
nicht okay ist das das
vorbereitet
und andere nicht ja wir haben ja auch
unsere
keine reiche Stadt ist und man muss doch
ehrlich sagen
der Finanzausgleich gar nicht mehr
existiert in der Form aber ich möchte
Mechanismus
Image dieser Stadt also von der Funktion
her also es gab glaube ich also so nach
in den 90ern hat Berlin dann sozusagen
diese diese Party Metropole gehabt jetzt
haben wir die nächste große Welle
nie wieder das Image ändert und zwar ist
halt so dieses Gendern und
Transsexuellen und so weiter die sehen
sich in Berlin nicht nee schon lange
nicht mehr die Zeit nicht vorbei
nicht bedroht und darum kommen
wahnsinnig viele Leute in die Stadt aber
das ist eine Stadt die permanent am
Tropf hängt die muss ich überlegen wie
komme ich von dem tropflos von dem
finanztraum
und Transsexuellen überhaupt nichts zu
tun
[Gelächter]
abgefahren Bayern war die ersten
Jahrzehnte ebenfalls ein agrarstadt war
ein Nimmerland aus dem damaligen
winterfinanzausgleich das Problem in
Berlin ist doch dass hier Wirtschaft
systematisch vergraut wird dass die
Probleme die diese Stadt hat
selber angesprochen sehen Sie denn den
Berliner Strauß der Strauß hat der den
Airbus geschafft also sehen Sie in
Berlin irgendwohin wo man sagen kann ja
da kommen sie jetzt hier richtig
losgehen mit der Wirtschaft wir haben
zum Beispiel gerade auf auf Bundesebene
den Weg frei gemacht für einen
translationszentrum für gehen und
zähltherapie in Berlin am Ende des Tages
können wir ja nicht den Arbeitsplätzen
der Vergangenheit und der Wirtschaft
nachhängen sollen wir müssen gucken was
die Entwicklung der Zukunft
ich will nicht auf auf einzelne Person
wir haben nicht mehr irgendwie den
Siemens oder wie auch immer wir müssen
gucken dass wir aus den voraussetzen und
die diese Stadt hat das Beste an
industrieller
Wertschöpfung für die nächsten
Jahrzehnte machen und da müssen wir mehr
in Forschung investieren dann müssen wir
unternehmen willkommen heißen da dürfen
wir nicht den Wohnungsbau so abwürgen
wie das in den letzten Jahren passiert
ist wir dürfen keine ideologischen
Experimente gegen den
Autoverkehr machen wir dürfen nicht
klimakleber bekommen heißen sondern wir
müssen am Ende des Tages ein Bild machen
dass diejenigen die Berlin interessant
und attraktiv finden hierher kommen hier
Geschäft machen wollen hier
Arbeitsplätze schaffen und damit dann
auch Wirtschaft
wir sind die Parteien die es ändern
wollen die jetzt zur Wahl treffen ich
glaube schon dass es in der Stadt einen
ganzen Menge Leute geben gibt die die
sich damit nicht mehr abgeben wollen
in Berlin das hoffe ich dass das die CDU
das ist die CDU ist ich hoffe auch nach
wie vor auf Teile der SPD und ansonsten
muss man sagen dass die das sind die für
diesen Neustart zur Verfügung stehen
wollen willkommen sind und das ist ja
genau das was Sie auf der anderen Seite
sagen müssen erstmal in ihrem Thema
vorhin dass wir jetzt eine uns ehrlich
machen müssen dass wir sagen müssen was
sind die Probleme und wer will daran
mitarbeiten an der Lösung und das
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil und das
Desaster vor einem Jahr bei der Wahl ist
so gravierend dass wir jetzt eine
Situation haben dass wir über die
Probleme in der Stadt wirklich reden
können und dass wir Lösungsansätze dafür
zur Wahl stellen können am 12 februar
und deswegen bin ich gar nicht so
pessimistisch
sie sind sehr leidenschaftlich dabei und
sie haben Lösungsansatz präsentiert das
müssen wir eine ganz kurz unterbrechen
weil dann wird Michael Nast
einlösungsansatz für die Gesellschaft
präsentieren bis gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig
realitätsfernsehen
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruhen hier ganz richtig was die
Frau Wagner Ich sag ehrlich gesagt ist
das fast total
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glööckler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst
haben wir haben zu viel Stahl wegfallen
und wir uns gegenseitig in Berlin Mitte
Cappuccinos verkaufen das funktioniert
nicht dann ist mit Wohlstand aber das
ist alles essen als freiheitsliebender
Mensch würde ich sagen das muss jedem
erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und umierungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch
was machbares ich finde aber diese
gesamte Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch
ein bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt über den Bericht
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und machen direkt weiter
mit der These von Michael nass den
Bestseller Auto der sagt er hat die
Lösung für Deutschland gefunden ich bin
gespannt naja die Lösung also das ist ja
die das ist eigentlich eine zwingende
Geschichte
die Frage die man sich vielleicht auch
stellen sollte was vielleicht auch zeigt
dass hier viele Diskussionen gerade ein
bisschen am Thema vorbeigegangen sind
ist ja letztendlich warum es seit Jahren
schon so viele Leute auf die Straße
treibt ja dann kommt Journalisten gehen
hin und gehen auf dieser
unterschiedlichen Demonstration und
stellen dann irgendwie fest naja es gibt
dann so sehr vielfältige Gründe aber es
gibt einen Grund ja die meisten dieser
Leute vereint warum die da hingehen und
das ist das ist existenzarzt also alle
Krisen der letzten Zeit Energiekrise
flüchtlingskrise das sind alles im
Grunde genommen Existenz eines Krisen
die Leute haben Angst durch diese Krisen
sich ihr Leben halt nicht mehr leisten
zu können und darum dass halt übrigens
Markus Lanz gesagt ist die große und ich
stimme ihm dabei ist die große Frage die
wir uns eigentlich beschäftigen sollte
die soziale Frage und darum ist die
Lösung für dieses Land unbedingt
das Bürgergeld was jetzt irgendwie da
abgewunken wurde finde ich jetzt auch
finde ich gar nicht so falsch dass es
nicht so umgesetzt wird weil es einfach
nicht zu Ende gedacht und nicht richtig
durchdacht wurde also bzw kommen das ist
die Lösung für uns alle der fragen wir
doch mal den Politik und wirtschaftschef
vom Bild direkt bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen ist dass die Lösung für
Deutschland nein das ist natürlich nicht
aber das hast du jetzt erwartet in
deiner Frage und hat er nass sicherlich
auch erwartet aber ich glaube das kann
auch kein ernst gemeinter Vorschlag sein
bei der Frage wie wollen wir dieses Land
voranbringen ein Land ist noch nie
vorangekommen das zeigt die ganze
Evolution die man sagt ich gebe dir
erstmal was fürs nichts tun oder guckst
du mal was dabei das ist ja genau das
und ich kenne die Argumente von ihnen
auch die können Sie gleich gern noch mal
wieder ausführen aber das darum geht es
am Ende ja sondern es gibt und das
wissen wir auch ein Hunger der Menschen
nach Leistung nach Bindung und nach
macht das sind die drei Dinge mitmachen
uns nicht gefallen aber so sind wir
Menschen gestrickt und es gibt ein
Streben auch Dinge zu verändern Dinge
besser zu machen und weil sie das Thema
Bürgergeld gerade Ansprachen das sind
die Anreize die eine Gesellschaft auch
setzen muss denn am Ende bezahlt ja die
Gesellschaft mit ihren Steuern
beispielsweise dass Menschen nicht
arbeiten das kann eigentlich nicht im
Interesse dieser Gesellschaft sein schon
gar nicht wenn sie schrumpft wie wir
sehen also immer mehr Menschen ins
Rentenalter gehen und zu wenig junge
Menschen nachwachsen zu sagen und jetzt
kannst du erstmal mit dem Geld 1000 €
1.500 im Monat machen was du willst und
ob du arbeitest oder nicht das stellen
wir dir frei das kann ich Sinn einer
Gesellschaft sein die schrumpft und
schon gar nicht im Sinne vieler vieler
Menschen die das finanzieren wollen das
ist eher glaube ich eine Hängematte für
jene die keine Lust haben zu arbeiten
das ist natürlich
klassische CSU fdp-rhetorik zu sagen die
Leute würden dann einfach
dann würde keiner mehr arbeiten also ich
würde sagen so ein bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen es geht nicht um
irgendwie 8000 Euro oder so Monat das
alle dann nichts mehr machen sondern es
geht einfach um eine Grundsicherung dass
ich nicht meine Entscheidung ständig
davon abgesehen Komma
finanzieren also wenn Sie meine bezahlen
vorstellen
das Geld aufbringen um einen Betrag 1000
1500 2000 Euro im Monat für 83 Millionen
Menschen unabhängig davon dass sie
gerade noch gesagt haben dass das auch
ein Problem werden was die
flüchtlingskrise lösen würde das also
offensichtlich alle Leute nehmen das
Geld bekommen
weil die denken warum auch immer die
Flüchtlinge kommen hierher Asylbewerber
und nehmen dann irgendwelche Geld aus
irgendwelchen Töpfen was ihnen dann
eigentlich zustehen würde was natürlich
völlig falsch ist denn das war da auch
nie vorgesehen nein es geht darum ich
rede von einer Grundsicherung aber
in den 70er Jahren
müssen wir haben um zu wissen
die Fixkosten die man hat hat
funktioniert das leider nicht also es
gab Experimente es gab Experimente alle
super funktioniert haben genauer
angeguckt die haben das ja alles
probiert es stellt sich heraus dass die
Produktivität runter geht das Problem
wird aber sein wir haben vielleicht
15 15 Millionen Leute die Steuern
bezahlen aus dem ersten heraus dann
haben wir noch mal ungefähr so viele die
kriegen das Geld vom Staat also die
Zahlen dann Steuern aus steuern das ist
nicht selbst erwirtschaftet wir haben
vielleicht zwei bis drei Millionen
Unternehmer die Leute
versicherungspflichtig anstellen und die
dann sagen wir mal zusammen mit 20 25
Millionen Leuten arbeiten und die da
Geld verdienen und die ziehen sozusagen
hier ganz Deutschland durch und den
muten wir dann zu dass sie zusehen wenn
sie selber nicht die Zeit haben und mit
ihrem Kind zu spielen weil sie auf
Arbeit gehen das andere die Zeit haben
weil sie von dem was sie an Steuern
bezahlen mitfinanziert werden schalte
das für außerordentlich schwierig das
wirkt sozialen Sprengstoff aus der Güte
und das Problem ist nun mal es ist ein
Industrieland wir können uns das Geld
für uns das Geld damit selber probieren
wir können das Geld gerne selber drucken
dann ist es aber nichts mehr
hören
da das Problem haben wir doch jetzt auch
mit dem Euro das heißt
schon schwächer geworden das hat auch
damit zu tun dass du gedruckt wird wie
geklappt da haben sie recht das ist
nicht der Punkt der Punkt ist bisher
galt es eigentlich dass der Kapitalstock
in Deutschland mit der Industrie stark
genug ist diese Schulden dann wieder
aufzuarbeiten das war bisher zumindest
bei den Märkten immer die Voraussetzung
weiterhin z.B den deutschen Kredite zu
geben wenn keiner mehr diese
Glaubwürdigkeit auf international
Märkten herstellen kann dann drücken wir
den sachsentaler und in Berlin Pfennig
und so ein und dann hat jeder diese
Geldscheine in der Hand und kann davon
nichts kaufen das können wir so machen
aber am Ende wird niemand nichts haben
können sie trotzdem sagen dürfen
Antworten
ich kann da keinen Wert sagen ich kann
nur sagen dass der der ein Irrglaube ist
dass dann die Leute plötzlich nicht mehr
arbeiten gehen das haben die Experimente
aber anders gezeigt und wenn es in der
überleben die man kann ja auch arbeiten
die relativ wenig verdienen Sachen du
weißt wenn ich mit dem Bürgergeld und
dem bezahlten Wohngeld und der bezahlten
Heizung auf selbe ungefähr rauskomme
dann bin ich doch nicht bekloppt und
gehe noch arbeiten dann mache ich am
Wochenende schwarz-weiß und habe noch
viel mehr auf der Tasche also das ist
doch absolutes Zeug was ihr gelabert
wird die Firmen die haben dann nachher
keine Möglichkeit mehr mit den
Mitarbeitern zu arbeiten die Sie
brauchen um produktiv zu sein und
Steuern zu bezahlen die wahrscheinlich
noch angehoben werden in der nächsten
Zeit um den ganzen sums zu bezahlen
warum haben wir denn aktuell gerade so
ein handwerkerproblem die Leute scheiden
sich ja gar nicht die scheinen auch
keine Arbeitskräfte zu kriegen gerade ja
aber das hat einen anderen Grund
da können wir vielleicht gleich die
beiden Themen auch miteinander reden
von Herrn nass mit deiner ja
geh direkt darauf einmal dass auch
natürlich sehr spannend ist was her nass
gerade gesagt hat am Ende geht es um die
Frage warum haben wir zum Beispiel ein
handwerkermangel in Deutschland ich
glaube und das ist meine These heute
abend dass die Regierung uns gar nicht
sagt so richtig wie schlechtes um dieses
Land eigentlich steht also sagt uns oder
malt das Land in einem besseren Farben
als es ist denn eins ist klar uns gehen
die Jobs aus nicht die Jobs aber uns
gehen die Arbeitskräfte das ist der
Punkt in 10 Jahren werden nach
berechnungsinstituts der deutschen
Wirtschaft und 5 Millionen Menschen zu
wenig bei uns am Arbeitsmarkt sein das
hat damit zu tun dass immer mehr
Menschen in Rente gehen aber zu wenig
junge Menschen in den Arbeitsmarkt
Streben und auch die andere Regierung
Herr Maja ich muss das leider sagen
setzt die falschen Anreize mit dem
Bürgergeld beispielsweise sicherlich
nicht dazu beiträgt den Druck einen Job
anzunehmen zu erhöhen
und auch mit dem Thema Rente da sehen
wir gerade was das Thema höhere und
längere Arbeitszeit Lebensarbeitszeit
angeht dass ich auch die ampelregierung
mitbeteilung der FDP nicht so richtig
durchreden kann auch da etwas zu tun
dass insgesamt mehr Menschen im
Arbeitsmarkt verbleiben so dass wir das
Problem dass sie auch gerade Ansprachen
hast den z.B handwerkermangel damit
lösen können
also zum einen bin ich ein Schäfer
dankbar dass er das Thema angesprochen
hat dass es um Deutschland nicht so gut
steht wie man vielleicht in der
öffentlichen Debatte den Eindruck
bekommen kann wenn man ehrlich sind ist
das ein Thema was seit 10 Jahren
Schleich Entwicklung ist wir haben
in den letzten zehn Jahren Steuer
Mehreinnahmen auf Bundesebene von 100
Milliarden Euro erwirtschaftet jährlich
weil es der Wirtschaft gut ging weil es
viele Arbeitsplätze gab weil damit viel
Steuern bezahlt wurden weil weniger
sozial Transfers ausgeschlossen
und das ist auch das Erfolgsrezept was
wir in den nächsten Jahren deswegen bin
ich ja auch vollkommen bei ihnen
sicherstellen müssen wir müssen wieder
für mehr Wirtschaftswachstum sorgen wir
müssen aus dieser Krise jetzt mit mehr
Wirtschaftswachstum rauskommt mit mehr
Menschen die in Beschäftigung kommen und
das ist die Lösung das ist zum Fach das
ist der Mangel wir haben seit
Jahrzehnten gesagt wir sind ein
Einwanderungsland wir müssen
qualifizierte Zuwanderung ermöglichen
aber zumindest ist es so dass auch da
die Vorgängerregierung dieses Thema
nicht angegangen sind wir müssen mehr
Menschen weil die geboten raten in
Deutschland so sind wie sie sind an
qualifizierten Zuzug ermöglichen um
genau diese
Arbeitsplätze die zukünftig nicht mehr
besetzt werden können besetzen zu können
müssen
weiter zu das unqualifizierte Migration
stattfindet jeden Tag und nicht und der
Punkt ist
nach Deutschland wenn Sie feststellen
dass sie keine Rente mehr bekommen in
einem System dass Sie einzahlen müssen
wenn sie deswegen haben wir ja deswegen
haben wir die aktienrente jetzt
gestartet wir werden am Ende des Tages
glaube ich wir sind gar nicht so weit
auseinander wir müssen gucken dass wir
mehr Arbeits den dem Arbeitsmarkt mehr
Arbeitskräfte zur Verfügung stellen dann
müssen wir alle Potenzial einstellen
Entlastung eine Steuerentlastung haben
wir gerade mit dem Abbau der kalten
Progression gemacht er sagt ja
richtig aber wir haben 45 Milliarden
Euro letztlich das hätte man vor einem
Jahr auch nicht geglaubt dass diese
Koalition 45 Milliarden Euro im
einkommensteuerbereich entlastet durch
eine Erhöhung des Grundfreiheit ehrlich
warum weil wir eine extrem hohe
Inflation haben und das Gesetz ist
vorsieht also gehen muss
nicht vor sondern die FDP hat es
durchgesetzt in harten Kämpfen mit den
Koalitionspartnern es gab andere
Kollektion fahren
ist es leider keine gesetzliche Frist
wir haben es nicht in Koalitionsvertrag
verhandeln können wir haben uns damit
durchgesetzt und das ist natürlich ein
Thema es gehört zu Ehrlichkeit dazu dass
wir in der Ampel drei Parteien haben die
natürlich diametral andere
programmatische Ansätze verfolgen wie
immer gesagt uns geht es um die
Entlastung der Menschen deswegen war das
Thema Abbau der kalten Progression
Steuerentlastung für uns ein zentrales
genau wir müssen einmal erklären klingt
so technisch dass man einmal sagt der
Staat hat Milliarden mehr einander
dadurch dass es eine Inflation
passiert ist nichts anderes als zu sagen
dass das wird deswegen mehr abschöpfen
beispielsweise darüber Lohnerhöhung das
geben wir den Menschen zurück das heißt
unterm Strich muss man sagen keine
Entlastung eigentlich nur ein fairer
ausgleichen ich glaube
andere Partner in in dieser Koalition
wollten das nicht sondern das Geld Preis
sind Sie bezahlt haben das ist natürlich
ein Thema wo wir alle
in jeder Koalition immer eine Situation
haben dass es Kompromisse gibt es ist
kein Geheimnis dass beim Thema
Bürgergeld wir im Bereich Bürgergeld als
FDP immer gesagt haben dass wir die
Zuverdienstgrenzen Kompromiss bis zur
Selbstaufgabe auch irgendwann bedeuten
nein bestimmt nicht weil am Ende des
Tages die FDP in den letzten Jahren ja
klar gemacht hat dass es halt Punkte
gibt Stichwort Schuldenbremse zum
Beispiel wo wir nicht bereit sind eine
Änderung aber davor zu nehmen
so das heißt es gibt rote Linien die wir
gestern
in den Koalition
ähm Vertrag und dazu stehen wir und
deswegen geht es nicht darum dass wir
über Selbstaufgabe reden sondern es gibt
in dieser Koalition die unterschiedliche
thematische Ansätze hat immer auch ein
Ringen um die richtige Lösung und ich
glaube die FDP Ansätze da drin
verhindern zumindest schlimmeres wenn
man die Programmatik von den anderen
guckt und da ist genau das Thema
Wirtschaftswachstum das Thema
fachkräftezuwanderung das Thema
Qualifizierung das Thema
Flexibilisierung des
Renteneintrittsalters ein Thema was die
FDP immer wieder anspricht
das war eine gute Wahlkampfrede Herr
Bayer ja genau also ihre Loyalität
übrigens zu ihrer Partei die merkt man
aus jeder Pore das ist was sehr
positives heutzutage mit mit durchgehen
lassen sie haben ja mitgestimmter
Koalition und auf der anderen Seite
reden sie davon dass wir mehr Fachkräfte
in der Produktion brauchen die würden
dann Schuh draußen also zum Thema
Bürgergeld nur drei Sätze für die
Antwort wegen der Sendezeit schade also
Bürgergeld hat einige sehr positive
Aspekte zu Verdienstgrenze wird
angehoben damit Leute mehr arbeiten und
nicht von staatlichen
Jugendlichen bei älteren Menschen und
was die Erhöhung der Regelsätze angeht
das ist ein Inflationsausgleich der
vorgezogen wurde der will ja sogar die
CDU jetzt mitmachen so dass wir am Ende
im Vermittlungsausschuss hoffe ich einen
guten Kompromiss hinkriegen der das was
vielleicht in dem Entwurf noch nicht so
gut war ähm Stichwort vielleicht
Karenzzeiten in der richtige Richtung
Patienten oder für ältere Leute ersetzen
doch keine Fachkräfte die gebraucht
werden
darum dass Menschen die von ALG2
momentan leben
Anreiz haben etwas dazu zu verdienen um
dann irgendwann in der Situation zu
kommen dass sie nicht mehr auf
Transferleistungen angewiesen sind warum
muss es gehen und das ist der ganze Sinn
von BürgerInnen am Ende der Sendung
angekommen was man auf jeden Fall sagen
muss ist die FDP ist mit Herrn mai hier
sehr engagiert und auch vorher haben und
alle anderen und ich das wollte meine
letzte Sendung für dieses Jahr ich bin
am 28 Februar zurück für Sie und bis
dahin wurde geht meine wunderbare
Kollegin und Patricia Platin wir sehen
uns am 28.02 wieder tschüss machen sie
es gut bis dahin
[Musik]